foreign
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
will be my flash finale video that's
right the very last episode of The Flash
and the end of the arrowverse as you
know so rip poor went out press F to pay
respects to the arrowverse also explain
what's happening now with the Flash
movie and all the big DC reboot stuff
and now they're sort of reorganizing the
way they do DC TV shows like the whole
way James Gunn is rebooting the DC
Universe is to be a little bit more like
the way that Marvel does their stuff
where they have Marvel Studios TV shows
on Disney plus like big budget shows
with the movie actors who also cross
back and forth between the TV shows and
the movies as opposed to the way the DC
used to do their TV shows completely
separately from the movies if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos I'm also
supposed to see The Flash movie next
week as soon as they let us I will post
a review of the movie but they only
spent about half of the final episode
with the actual conflict like the
villains versus The Flash the second
half of the episode was basically
wrapping up all the character works and
setting up what's going to be happening
in this future timeline where they leave
things like the new world title of the
episode this Last Arc the way that Grant
Gustin talks about it he said he's
always game to come back like Stephen
Amell said the same thing too they would
love to come back and do like a limited
series or some HBO Max or now it's just
called Max some special they only come
back for a couple episodes okay okay
let's go all right let's go we'll see if
they ever wind up doing that I think
it's a Never Say Never kind of situation
like John Wesley's ship probably never
expected to come back and play The Flash
but he did come back several times as
several different characters like he did
during this episode there were lots of
cameos because it is the finale the
episode starts with the same opening
narration from the pilot episode he
gives the exact same speech you have to
believe in the impossible
to understand what I'm about to tell you
you need to do something first
[Music]
to understand what I'm about to tell you
you need to do something first they
repeat it during the episode a couple
different times like Keon references it
and then he also says it at the very end
of the episode when he's talking to Nora
baby Nora just in general there were
several lines of dialogue during the
finale that referenced either earlier
lines of dialogue or just moments from
across the history of the show like the
biggest moments with all the villains
cobalt blue was essentially the main
villain of the finale though even though
it brought back all the Flash's biggest
villains from earlier points in the
timeline the whole idea is the negative
speed force wanted to create a new
timeline where that positive speed force
where Barry never existed so we could
just grow unchecked so it brought back
all these different villains from across
their timeline right before the flash
kill them which is the twist that they
used during Spider-Man no way home it
was very Spider-Man no way home kind of
situation where all the Sinister Six
villains were pulled right before they
were killed battling the flash it was
the same thing with the Speedster
villains they were all joint from the
timeline right before they died in
battle or were changed or fundamentally
trapped for All Time by The Flash the
negative speed force essentially
resurrected Eddie Thon from the end of
season one like this is the dead Eddie
that died during season one and turned
him into the new reverse flash even
though they're calling him cobalt blue
like he's the new Avatar of the negative
speed force so essentially going forward
in this new version of the timeline he
is like the replacement for the reverse
flash in the comics cobalt blue was
Malcolm Thon he was like this long-lost
brother of Barry Allen in the TV show
world when the negative speed force
resurrected him he was going by the name
Malcolm in this future timeline the
whole idea with the cobalt blue
storyline in the comics is that they
were like a line of the Thon family like
the reverse flash family across history
that battled The Flash family if you're
a big anime fan it was kind of like
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure with the Joe
Stars battling Dio across their family
history Zoom comes back the Harrison
Wells reverse flash savitar godspeed and
even though the negative speed force
doesn't really care about any of these
other villains it just uses them to try
and fight the flash to kill him that's
the whole idea they even referenced that
during the episode like does the
negative speed force even care about you
teddy Sears Zoom is the first one to
come back from the end of season two
right before he was turned into the new
black flash so he doesn't remember
anything that happened after the end of
season two Tony Todd also came back to
do the voice of Zoom when he was wearing
the mask he also just did the voice of
the new Venom character in Spider-Man 2
which I just did a trailer video for so
I'll post links with that down in the
description below
we
there's also a rumored that Teddy Sears
had a cameo in The Flash movie like they
had a CW TV show Cameo during The Flash
movie but it wasn't Grant Gustin it was
actually Teddy Sears playing a version
of Jay Garrick so it's all wonky like
wait a minute he was 100 Solomon why did
cameos Jay Garrick in The Flash movie I
haven't seen the movie yet I'm supposed
to see it next week so we'll see what
winds up happening I'm sure there will
be lots of discussion about this Grant
Gustin claims he's not in The Flash
movie but he might be lying no yeah
there's been a lot of rumors out there
for a long time and no one's like come
out directly and asked me like ever like
you know on the record godspeed gets
joint from right before team flash
defeated him it was fun to see the
villains share scenes together like they
chewed all the scenery and they made fun
of each other like you would expect like
a lot of the dialogue in the episode is
the writers also making fun of
themselves in previous seasons of The
Flash lick reverse flash making fun of
Zoom for being derivative copying his
move of pretending to be team Flash's
Ally because that was one of the
complaints after season two in real life
but the fans are like wait a minute this
is just like the season one story he
also calls him a velocity nine junkie
because that was basically the season
two storyline then doing the velocity
nine from the comics Tobin Bell also
came back as the voice of savitar most
of you will remember him as jigsaw from
the Saw movies they also wind up
changing savitar's color from Blue to
Red after the negative speed Force
brings them back empowering them because
the negative speed force is red when
reverse flash makes fun of Eddie Thon
calling him the dumbest branch on his
family tree that's just another
reference to the way the cobalt blue
storyline plays out in the comics across
the entire family line of the thawns
they briefly reference Eddie thon's
familial connection with eobarathon
during season one too just briefly they
used a lot of the same twists from
previous Seasons callbacks to previous
episodes like bigger episodes like
stealing more speed force energy when
Jay Garrett comes back saying that he
learned the trick quote unquote from his
friend on Earth 90 which is also a
reference to John Wesley ship playing
the Barry Allen from the 90s Flash TV
show coming back during crisis on
infinite Earths so it's basically John
Wesley ship saying he learned a trick
from himself they also had a new Flash
logo at the beginning highlighted with a
cobalt blue energy for this Last Arc of
the show the whole thing with the title
a new world like I said is meant to be a
reference to the Last Arc In general the
reference to the timeline the villains
are trying to create create a completely
new timeline where they survive and
cobalt blue basically replaces The Flash
as the only Speedster on the planet
because he also kind of plans to get rid
of the villains too it's also a
reference at the end of the episode
where the flash creates this new world
this new timeline where he doesn't
disappear like the future newspaper said
so he creates another new timeline again
which he's done many times on the show
they're also using that twist during The
Flash movie but in a slightly different
way like they're doing a version of
Flashpoint but it's a very different
amalgam version of Flashpoint there were
a bunch of other cameos Stephen Amell
did not come back but they do reference
Oliver Queen at the end of the episode
referencing his speech during the pilot
episode saying that the lightning chose
Berry when Barry says he's going to
choose the other new speedsters they
didn't have any more Flash movie
crossover scenes or references like Ezra
Miller didn't have any kind of Cameo
scenes or anything like that and they
didn't reference Grant Gustin being in
The Flash movie and Cisco also did not
come back John Wesley's ship obviously
came back as a version of Jay Garrick
Michelle Harrison who also plays Barry's
mother and a bunch of other characters
came back again as his wife Joan Garrick
from that Earth they brought back the
speed force lightsabers that was a big
twist in previous Seasons Nora comes
back from the future and they also
reference the events of season 3 with
savitar impaling Iris when he tries to
kill Nora Chester Runk almost gets
killed by a reverse flash and the
process becomes the chunk version of his
character from the comics like his whole
name Chester Runk is Chunk in the comics
but when they debuted him on the show
they just called him Chester he got
black hole power so they're just saying
that now he's more like the comic book
version of his character the whole
reason he doesn't wind up killing cobalt
blue at the end of the episode is to
save Eddie thon's life because he's
basically been perverted by the negative
speed force he winds up forming a truce
with the negative speed force which
leaves Eddie Thon as the new Avatar kind
of like the new reverse flash like I
said even though he'll always go by the
cobalt blue name when they say they'll
have disagreements in the future that
just means that they'll continue finding
each other in the future like they'll
continue having Adventures after this
last episode and essentially it's all
done by about halfway through the
episode like they form their truce and
they go their separate ways Nora is born
and then they basically wrap up all the
rest of the character arcs the original
Harrison Wells who had not become
reverse flash comes back because he
turned into a cosmic version of his
character and then kind of departed in
previous Seasons he tells kyoncinis to
ascend so if you're not familiar with
what's going on with killer frost they
changed her character so many times over
the seasons if you checked out she died
fighting a version of Death Storm when
she was resurrected she basically became
a God the god part of her had to ascend
leaving behind the human form of Caitlyn
snow so she's kind of like the season
one version of Caitlyn snow but she has
all the memories from the past couple of
Seasons Joe S winds up proposing to
Cecile because even though they had a
baby together and they've been living
together for years they never actually
got married Nora's crib her baby onesie
also decorated with her comic book
excess symbols her eyes flashing with
speed force energy is just to remind you
that she will become a Speedster in the
future and he explains that his whole
reason for creating the new speedsters
at the end of the episode is to help
protect Nora essentially so that he
doesn't have to spend his entire time
protecting the rest of the world there
are other speedsters that they can rely
on he goes back to the same Airfield
from Ferris air Big Green Lantern
reference from the pilot episode they
went back there a couple times
throughout different seasons and
essentially empowers three new
speedsters from the comics so they do
Max Mercury finally doing the character
on the show there's been so many
theories about his character for so long
like they had Mercury Labs going back to
season one but we never actually saw Max
Mercury this is Avery ho who in the
comics became the flash of China this is
Jess Chambers who also became the flash
of a different Earth and did just travel
the Multiverse but on the show they're
just explaining that all these
characters come from Central City and
they'll work with Team flash at the
collider and that's basically it and
this is what Grant Gustin has said about
the ending that sort of coincides with
my theory from many many years ago when
I thought about it ending there was a
theory out there that Barry would
sacrifice himself to keep the speed
force alive and become the lightning
bolt that inevitably struck him and
create this full circle moment which I
thought was really cool and I always
kind of wanted him to die a hero's death
in a way and I Eric um
was very opposed to the idea what my
original theory was is that they should
actually just do a version of the comic
book story it was a really small story
but it was essentially Barry Allen
becoming the bolt of lightning that gave
him powers in the first place so the
whole idea is that this was tied to
crisis on infinite Earth in the comics
and Barry sacrifices himself during that
comic book storyline to stop the
anti-monitor and he seemingly dies but
what really wound up happening is that
he traveled so quickly that he turned
into the bolts of lightning that
originally gave him Powers becoming the
flash so the whole idea in the TV show
is that it would have been really cool
for them to bookend the series where he
basically creates a Time Loop where he
becomes the bolt of lightning that
originally gave him Powers so like the
show season one to season 9 is a big
loop it was cool to find out that Grant
Gustin also wanted that ending for a
while but the current flash showburner
said that they changed that they wanted
to give him a happy ending I think just
because they wanted a happy episode of
TV for a serious finale I don't know if
that's better you can decide like you
watch and you decide whether or not you
wanted the more hardcore ending or the
happier ending as for The Flash movie
we'll see whether or not Grant Gustin is
lying about actually having a cameo in
it because it would really suck if he
didn't have a cameo like if we're ending
the flash wouldn't it be cool to see him
pay off that moment from crisis on
infant Earth's with some real quick kind
of Cameo seen in the speed force my
review of that will post as soon as they
let us do that I'm not sure when the
embargoes up for that all the new DC tv
shows will be big budget Max series kind
of like Peacemaker the work like the
Disney plus Marvel series the next one
that's going to Premiere is going to be
the Batman HBO series based on Robert
Pattinson's Batman with the penguin
character I will do episode videos for
all that stuff whatever they wind up
releasing whatever shows I will do
videos for it so don't worry about that
I did a trailer video for that just a
little while ago so I'll link that Below
in the description too over the many
years I had a ton of fun doing videos
about the arrowverse and I will say one
of the most fun things that ever
happened to me doing videos for the
arrowverse stuff is that really early on
when I first started making videos
Stephen Amell was like one of the first
people whoever actually said anything
nice about my videos which is really
cool of him that was almost like 10
years ago that's how long it's been
there's a bunch of really big stuff
coming up so I'll try to make videos for
everything everyone click here for all
my brand new Flash trailer videos and
click here for my brand new Blue Beetle
trailer video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and I'll see
you guys in the next one
[Music]
foreign